ils justice toujours avec une
confirmation dans le dossier moussaoui
accusé vous le savez de participation
aux attentats du 11 septembre
le département américain de la justice
va requérir la peine de mort annonce
officielle donc fait en milieu
d'après-midi premières réactions
recueillies tout à l'heure près de
montpellier
celle de la mère de zacarias moussaoui
moi je demande procès équitable pour mon
fils va là qu'est ce que je demande
qu'est ce que c'est un procès équitable
de montrer d'un côté ou de l'autre les
preuves
voilà si au nom des prévenus par les
montrer comme ça on n'a rien à dire
chaque année si on a fait une faute on
on paye mais c'est hélas rien fait non
je regrette mon fils moi je considère
mon fils est un bouc émissaire c'est
tout